le président du modem le mouvement
démocrate françois bayrou réagi sur
public sénat à la première conférence de
presse de françois hollande bonsoir on
sait merci d'avoir accepté donc
l'invitation de preuves par 3 en
partenariat avec l' agence france-presse
représenté dans un instant par jean
dupré vaut pour les questions
économiques l'oeuvre de redressement
revendiqué par le chef de l'état qui dit
se battre tous les jours perrine
tarneaud abordera avec vous un thème qui
était au coeur on s'en souvient de votre
campagne présidentielle françois bayrou
la rénovation de la vie politique a
tenté également été abordée par le chef
de l'état les téléspectateurs peuvent
intervenir comme chaque semaine par le
biais de l'application tivi tchèque
d'orange d'abord françois bayrou
comment est ce que vous avez trouvé
françois hollande dans le style le ton
une voie fermée ce qu'il y avait là un
premier message pour vous la première
question qu'on se pose lors de la
première conférence de presse d'un
nouveau président de la république c'est
toujours un événement en france
la première question c'est est ce qu'il
a été à la hauteur de sa fonction est
pour moi la réponse est oui il a été à
la hauteur de sa fonction il a été
précis dans l'expression il a été
maîtrisé
il a été convaincant je trouve et il
maîtrisait les sujets qu'il abordait ça
se voyait
ne serait ce que dans l'aisance physique
qui était la sienne donc premier point
il a été à la hauteur de la fonction
joli compliment
oui mais bon
on a des fonctions dire les choses moi
je fais la viande la présidence il
trouve la mesure de la fonction c'est
pas facile d'entrer dans la fonction de
président de la république surtout quand
on a le parcours qui est le sien et donc
de ce point de vue là je trouve que
c'était bon que ça avait du poids 2.5
fonds ou là leur deuxième point les
questions de fond bon il a usé un peu
d'énergie a expliqué qu'il n'y avait pas
eu de tournant du tout évidemment tout
le monde voit bien qu'il y a eu une
réorientation très importante
au passage c'est celle que j'annonçais
j'avais dit devra changer de politique
économique
c'est fait il dit c'est une politique de
l'offre par rapport à une politique de
la demande c'est-à-dire une politique de
soutien à l'entreprise par rapport à une
politique de distribution d'argent
public et il le fait et c'est juste
alors elle a notamment perçu presque une
un changement historique de la part de
la gauche est de françois hollande est
ce que vous avez eu confirmation lors de
cette conférence de presse qu'il prenait
effectivement qu'on vous voyez gros
titres sur la compétitivité des
économies là est un changement
historique
un changement historique le ministre de
l'économie a dit une révolution il a
même ajouté copernicienne se souvenir du
grand astronome copernic avait trouvé
que la terre tournait autour du soleil
et pas le contraire
elle est la contribution que le terrain
est bien sûr c'est une révolution
copernicienne et en courant et c'est
très important mais en ce que au lieu de
passer par les classiques de la gauche
qui sont la dépense publique la
multiplication des postes des
allocations des subventions toutes ces
choses qui ont fait le le fond
idéologique de la gauche depuis des
années on va au contraire c'est à dire
en dix ans la création de richesses et
la création d'emploi c'est dans les
entreprises que ça se passe un truc
sympa sur les entreprises qu'il faut
aider et dans le 200 m
c'est évidemment une réorientation très
intense au vert au voc est jaloux de
votre indépendance vis-à-vis de la
droite comme vis-à-vis de la gauche est
ce que vous avez donc entendue
lors de cette conférence de presse un
président marquée à gauche non je dirais
pas ça je pense que là la fonction
présidentielle
d'ailleurs françois hollande l'a dit un
peu c'est une fonction qui doit
absolument échapper aux partis et même
au camp le président de la république il
est marqué dans sa fonction par
l'intérêt général
enfin bon comme un prix d'engagement par
alors non et de l'ingérence par son
passé oui par ses amis oui par sa
majorité qui peut quelquefois être une
gêne mais le président de la république
il n'est pas le président d'un camp
indique mois atteint 12 arrêts parce que
françois bayrou j'ai l'impression que
vous avez assisté à la conférence de
presse d'un président que vous auriez
aimé aimé être un jeu on est tous
différents mais vous savez que j'ai voté
pour lui et il y avait ce soir je crois
aux yeux de tous les observateurs je
parlais avant d'entrer dans votre
mission avec des économistes avec des
sondages de sondage et tout le monde
voyait bien que cette orientation là
était en phase avec les raisons pour
lesquelles j'ai pensé alors allez une
alternance en france évolution est en
phase avec ce que vous aviez annoncé ce
que vous aviez espéré françois bayrou ne
met pas forcément les électeurs à avec
les électeurs de françois n'ont pas tous
entonné calmez vous avez raison de bure
et là vous vous parliez vous dites c'est
de la blague koala l'absence de
changement et certains parlent de
reniement dont je enfin moi je dirais
pas ça mais d'abord parce que j'essaie
de jamais utiliser de mots excessifs
mais en effet le projet sur lequel
françois hollande s'est fait élire et la
majorité qui est la sienne n'était
probablement pas ce que nous sommes en
train de vivre aujourd'hui ni en phase
avec ce que nous sommes en train de
vivre aujourd'hui il n'y avait pas
d'autre solution
la situation du pays n'ouvrait pas
d'autres possibilités
vous savez à quel point ça a été
difficile pour y compris un certain
nombre de mes amis de de suivre le choix
qui avait été fait on voit a été
difficile pour vous sur vos amis c'est
ceci est la vie quand on ouvre des
chemins nouveaux réflexes forcément
forcément il ya des difficultés pour
ceux qui sont à l'avant-garde accord
c'est même pour ça que les abords garçon
fait mais c'est une enfin c'est positif
de voir si on peut se définir par le
gène et françois alors non
l'applaudissant à tour ont d'abord je ne
la produit pas pas de question je dis ce
que je serais d'accord si j'avais pensé
que ça n'allait pas je serai à votre
micro en train de le dire de la même
alors jamais bossé avec vous avez dit
quelques chantiers pas très juste vous
avez dit quelque chose qui est très
juste vous avez dit vous qui êtes jaloux
de votre indépendance
qu'est ce que c'est l'indépendance c'est
de pouvoir dire ce qu'on pense l'accent
être contraint par son camp après ses
intérêts de parti vous avez un quota
réservé cette émission j'ai envie de
vous dire est ce que vous pourriez
néanmoins travailler demain avec
françois hollande mais le chaque fois
que la politique ira dans le sens de ce
que je considère ces levées là vous
l'avez chaque fois celle j'en serai là
ont soutiré 7/4 et chaque fois que la
politique choisira d'autres cap
je serai là pour m'y opposer ceci est la
vertu de la liberté très bien alors la
liberté un jour de travailler avec un
françois hollande alors dont nous avons
joué comme ans à quelle place
vous voulez bien comprendre que je pose
pas les problèmes sous l'angle personnel
oui mais moi si si ça avait été le cas
que je les pose sous l'angle personnel
c'est moi qui vont probablement
aurais-je eu plus de facilité et de
confort
la vie politique mais ça y est
maintenant là vous acceptez
vous applaudissez le changement vous en
tirer des conséquences dans votre
relation pour germer par le chef de
l'état j'ai une comment dirais-je j'ai
une franchise de relations avec le
président de la république que j'ai
d'ailleurs eu avec ses prédécesseurs que
je sois pour encontre j'ai eu la même
liberté d'expression et je la
conserverai ce dont manque que la france
cruellement
ce sont des esprits libres très bien
vous avez écouté les réactions ce soir
eh bien écoutez prenons-les le les
réactions de l'opposition même si l'on
pense du bien
elles sont forcément négative les
réactions de la majorité même s'il leur
arrive de penser du mal elles sont
forcément positive en tout cas celle du
parti ou alors est donc les esprits
libres ils sont capables de dire oui
quand c'est bien et non quand c'est mal
alors et c'est un changement se fasse
pareil quand nous l'aurons conduit alors
revenons à ce qu'a dit le chef de l'état
françois fillon qui a écouté comme vous
le chef de l'état lui il voit toujours
un président qui en france un peu plus
sa tête dans le sable donc manifestement
et lui il n'y a pas de virage 1
il est en campagne pour la présidence de
l'ump en vain considérons que ce sont
des péchés véniels alors un je poursuis
ma question est ce que vraiment vous
voyez dans les mesures qui ont été
annoncées par le chef de l'état qui
était d'ailleurs déjà connu sur la
compétitivité un espoir pour redresser
l'outil industriel de notre pays en tout
cas à la question est-ce que ça va dans
le bon sens ont la réponse est oui
il n'y a pas de référence sur un serveur
mais elles vont venir en venir l'annoncé
mais je vous dis avec certitude
n'est ce pas le le le défi auquel la
france est confrontée le la montagne qui
est devant nous que d'autres pays
européens ont franchi les allemands les
premiers que dans la douleur l'europe du
sud est en train de franchir pour
retrouver la capacité de notre pays dans
la très dure compétition internationale
va imposer ses réformes notamment la
réforme du marché du travail et pour
moi notamment la réforme du marché du
travail et peut-être même la réforme du
temps de travail parce que on est un
pays qui a besoin de d'agir sur les
seuls leviers qui n'entraîneront pas le
plus grave qui est pour moi la grèce des
bulletins de salaire et la belle n'avait
pas leur camp par exemple jean marc
ayrault il ya quelques semaines dans une
interview au parisien jean marc ayrault
qui a été loué pour toutes ces qualités
par le chef de l'état annonce
effectivement qu'il faut aussi accepter
de débattre de la fin des 35 heures il
disait vrai en fait disait ce qu'il
pensait
les adresses ce qu'il pensait et
peut-être aussi une partie de ses
arrière pensées
alors il a été vilipendé insulté il a dû
faire marche arrière
toutes ces choses que nous connaissons
bien mais qu'est ce qu'on préfère agir
sur le marché du travail un jour sur les
horaires de travail ou baisser les
bulletins de salaire et avoir une
multiplication des chômeurs moi je vous
dis que ceux qui nous écoutent et qui
sont des travailleurs qu'il faudrait de
devenir préfère avoir un travail d'avoir
un salaire convenable même s'il faut
organiser un peu différemment la vie de
travail c'est pas la mer à boire c'est
pas le bout du monde et je pense alors
j'ai écouté ce que françois hollande a
dit sur les partenaires sociaux j'espère
que les partenaires sociaux vont se
saisir de cette question mais de leur
somme de s'entendre mais de toute façon
nous serons obligés de nous poser ces
questions là parce que la réalité ne
nous laissera pas le choix c'est un
satisfecit sur toute la ligne
ah ben non parce que cette dernière
n'avait pas encore franchi sûr mais
enfin vous vous êtes confiant et on y
viendra
oui non ce n'est pas confiant quel que
soit le gouvernement il sera obligé
d'aller dans ce sens là on aurait
peut-être pu y aller plutôt où on aurait
peut-être dû y aller plus tôt on aurait
peut-être dû faire des choses plus nette
mais il y avait une condition à tout ça
c'était qu'on soit capable de rassembler
les grands un sensibilités politiques du
pays beaucoup des vocations de la
justice une des réformes justes par
françois hollande c'est ça la différence
entre la droite et la gauche pour vous
la juge
si c'est la condition de la réforme
parce que les sondages d'impopularité
vous semble injuste pour le chef de
l'état et l'exécutif on a écouté les
sondages ça va ça vient
et quant aux cantonales mais vous en
avez une expérience de la vie politique
on sait qu' il n'y a rien de fixé dans
les sondages dans les mouvements
d'opinion
il ya des moments où l'opinion vous en
temps il ya des moments où l'opinion ne
vous entend pas ça ne doit influer en
rien sur votre ligne
ça peut influer sur votre style il ya
toujours à apprendre sans doute on est
un certain nombre à avoir l'expérience
qui fait qu' on n'attache pas une très
grande importance à tout ça mais ça ne
doit pas vous amener à bouger dès
dimanche
ce soir vraiment vous ne regrettez pas
votre vote pour françois hollande n'ont
fait conforter dans votre joue un pays
avait besoin d'alternance vous savez le
le jour où j'ai fait ce choix
je crois que la phrase que j'ai utilisé
le soir même ou le lendemain matin a été
la france a besoin d'alternance et la
gauche a besoin de découvrir le réel et
je pense que la france avait aussi
besoin que la gauche découvre le réel
comprenez le la gauche a passé des
années à nier la nécessité des réformes
est donc cette nouvelle étape dans
laquelle elle va elle même conduire ces
réformes c'est selon moi très positif
pour le pays
alors françois hollande qui n'est pas
sensible où on land bashing il l'a dit
nos confrères réunis à l'elysée ce mardi
s'est flatté d'avoir réorienter l'europe
mais la france devient elle le maillon
faible apparemment de la zone euro au
risque de l'entraîner vers le fonds en
tous les cas c'est
la france bashing lefranc bashing qui a
cours en ce moment en allemagne et c'est
ce que nous montre fabrice canet juste
avant d'accueillir jean louis prévost de
l' agence france-presse
le french bashing c'est le nouveau jeu à
la mode de l'autre côté du rhin la
presse allemande a fait c'est une sur le
péril français le journal bild allant
jusqu'à comparer la france avec la grèce
évidemment c'est pour faire peur c'est
tout à fait dans la tradition de ce
quotidien cyniquement on pourrait déjà
dire que peut-être la grèce ne fait plus
peur donc il faut donc trouver d'autres
boucs émissaires il faut trouver
d'autres épouvantail
et pourquoi pas la france mais il n'ya
pas que la presse qui s'inquiètent de
gerhard schröder à l'actuel ministre des
finances wolfgang schaeuble eux chacun y
va de son conseil de sa mise en garde
il se trouve que j'ai fait un choix et
bhl est le seul véritable nom européen
du gang moralement que ces propositions
il ya bien des années ont été dures au
bout c'est par paris et que vraiment il
veut que la france fasse une autre
politique
est ce que c'est un peu un grand
peut-être mais nous nous avons été
donneurs de leçons à des tas d'endroits
mon gouvernement a pris la pleine mesure
de la gravité de la situation
pas assez répondent les allemands la
france minimiserait l'ampleur de la
crise pire ces réponses serait inadapté
débat sur quoi faire reste were n'avons
pas la même vision que les allemands
donc on peut continuer à se servir et
recevoir ça mais je pense qu'ils doivent
s'aperçoit en ce moment même que c'est
tombé juste après donc sans tenir compte
de nos temps débute prise de confiance
vue prise de conscience du gouvernement
et du président et moi pour ma part je
trouve qu'il était bien tard mais
qu'heureusement et que c'est une bonne
mesure mais alors pourquoi un tel
acharnement
une partie de la réponse serait dans le
contexte politique
achtung angela merkel est en campagne
angela merkel à elle a tout intérêt pour
sa compagne électorale
pas être trop optimiste tandis que
françois hollande y lui il est déjà
confronté avec un pessimisme très fort
en france donc il a tout intérêt à dire
et à raconter une histoire qui va plutôt
dans le sens tout n'est pas noir
pierre moscovici a tenu à dédramatiser
les critiques venues d'allemagne et le
gouvernement héros renvoie gentiment son
voisin aux résultats attendus de sa
politique
je vous adore il sera donc très
intéressant de voir quel est l'impact de
cette conférence de presse de françois
hollande partout en europe
maintenant en allemagne à bruxelles jean
louis prévost de l'agencé france presse
nous avons rejoint bonsoir jean louis
bonsoir en question à françois bayrou
bruxelles le fait ni j'attende tout des
réformes importantes des réformes
structurelles importantes de la france
où est-ce qu'on en est votre avis pour
le monde qu'on a changé d'orientation
c'est à dire qu'on a abandonné ce
qu'était la doctrine classique de la
gauche française comme vous dites en
termes savants keynésienne et même
parfois ultra keynésienne qui disait au
fond la relance doit se faire par la
dépense publique et on est passé à une
autre logique que je considère comme
beaucoup plus juste est beaucoup plus
fondée que on appelle la politique de
l'offre c'est l'expression que françois
hollande a reprise c'est à dire à cette
idée que c'est dans l'entreprise que ça
se joue et qu'il faut soutenir
l'entreprise pour qu'elle présente de
nouveaux produits qu'elles adoptent de
nouveaux processus de
fabrication d'élaboration et que c'est
comme ça que nous allons retrouver notre
rang c'est un changement très profond
c'est de nature à rassurer pour
reprendre la question de jean louis
l'allemagne par exemple des cinq sens en
tout cas que c'est un signe positif à
l'égard de nos partenaires européens
simplement évidemment il suffit pas d'en
parler il faut aller au bout avancer
vers les grandes réformes dans la france
a besoin qu'ils n'ont pas été adoptées
dans les années précédentes en partie
parce que la gauche s'y opposaient et
donc par exemple la réforme du droit du
travail
c'est un fait une grande réforme qui
sera pas simple à élaborer
pas simple à mettre en oeuvre mais il
n'existe aucune possibilité d ud7 re
reconstruction dont nous avons besoin
pour que notre pays est ce que ces
réformes structurelles ne tarde pas un
peu l'italie de mario monti par exemple
les a engagés depuis un an
et là en france ça fait six mois que le
monsieur hollande est arrivé à la
présidence de la république l'a fallu
fermer tout à ses six mois d'observation
du temps perdu
probablement en réseau nos partenaires
allemands souviendrai sans doute que sur
ce sujet en 2011 avant la campagne
présidentielle j'ai publié un livre dans
le titre disait l'essentiel état
d'urgence
l'allemagne a fait ça ya huit ans
l'italie a commencé ça en effet de
manière sérieuse il ya un an ou un an et
demi bien sûr que nous avons du retard
et c'est parce que nous avons du retard
que nous avons ce gouffre du commerce
extérieur c'est parce que nous avons du
retard que nous avons le chômage qui
galopent en france d'autant plus
important est la nécessité de définir
clairement les lignes que nous avons à
suivre et d'affronter les secousses qui
ne manqueront pas de naître
à partir de cette nouvelle définition
parce que
comme vous le sentez bien il y aura
forcément des problèmes de majorité ou
de soutien populaire autour de saisir
votre avis est ce que les mesures
décidées la semaine dernière par le
gouvernement pour soutenir la
compétitivité des entreprises sera
suffisant relancer l'économie française
bon alors dans leurs orientations sont
justes dans leur définition elle pose
des questions
j'ai trouvé je les dis que c'était bien
compliqué que c'était repoussé à 2014
c'était de la sous forme de crédit
d'impôt suis pas sûr que ça donne l'élan
nécessaire aux entreprises je me suis
exprimé sur ce sujet avec crainte qu'ils
y est qu'il n'y ait trop de contraintes
administratives vous savez qu'il ya des
gens qui disent au parlement on va
mettre des contraintes on va exiger des
contreparties
on demandera des contrôles si on fait
tout ça évidemment ça sera encore eu
davantage amoindrir l'efficace avait des
inquiétudes donc le rapport aux gallois
n'a pas été totalement traduit comme l'a
dit le chef de l'état dont il a fait
orgue mis aussitôt traduit non pas
vraiment il a été prise en compte pour
une réorientation des principes de la
politique suivie et c'est déjà beaucoup
d'accord alors lis un point du rapport
gallois qui avait été tout de suite
écarté qui est l'exploitation des gaz de
schiste mal apparemment le président de
la république a fait une ouverture
aujourd'hui en disant qu'il était
possible le jour où de nouvelles
techniques d'exploitation seront
possibles de d'envisager cette
exploitation il a il a dit autre chose
il est allé beaucoup plus loin que ça le
rapport gallois disait reprendre les
recherches sur les procédés d'extraction
des gaz de schiste je crois aussi que je
cite à peu près exactement la
proposition du rapport gallois avait
déjà enterré tout de suite allé aux
jeunes des banlieues est aujourd'hui
françois hollande a dit mais la
recherche elle est ouverte
et vous votre proposition sur ce je suis
absolument de cet avis je ne je ne crois
pas possible qu'un pays comme le nôtre
refuse de se poser la question d'une
richesse qu'il aurait dans son sous-sol
et qu'ils refuseraient d'exploiter après
on prend les précautions nécessaires
je suis l'élu du département du gaz de
lacq
croyez-moi le gaz de lacq ça n'était pas
tout à fait un produit pour bébés 1c
vous vous souvenez du 2 de cet énorme
charge de soufre qu'il y avait dans le
gaz de lacq et le soufre c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on peut répandre dans
l'atmosphère de cette manière là et on
l'a pourtant exploiter ça a donné à la
france
venant de chez nous sous sol des
pyrénées cinquante années de deux de
production de gaz et donc d'amélioration
de son indépendance énergique la nôtre
choc de compétitivité il est là sous nos
pieds elle est bien ri à la quelque
chose qu évidemment aucun gouvernement
sérieux ne peut éluder ou écarter du
revers de la main
est ce que françois hollande a dit est
un pas évidemment très très important
vous êtes entendu cela pose quand même
un problème au niveau de la composition
du gouvernement réel parce que madame et
monsieur zéro des partenaires qui
refusent j'ai dit tout à l'heure dans la
première partie de cette interview que
selon moi il y avait deux difficultés
devant le président de la république la
première difficulté était la manière
dont son projet avait été présenté aux
français qui je crois n'a vait pas
compris exactement ce que le
gouvernement était en affaires la
deuxième c'était la majorité bien sûr
que sa majorité et de ce point de vue là
fragile et on en voit tous les jours des
exemples et on va en voir des exemples
dans les semaines et les mois qui
viennent parce que cet axe dont je me
félicite et que j'avais prévu quand j'ai
voté pour françois hollande
cet axe là il est bien sûr incompatible
avec un certain nombre de sensibilité
qui sont affichés dans la majorité qui
sont géographiquement mais qui n'y sont
pas politiquement qu'il faudra dessiner
à l'avenir une nouvelle majorité je
savais ce que j'abordais les jeux tout à
l'heure tu m'as héros
c'est sans fin de la fracturation
hydraulique là il ya une fracturation
majoritaire allaient me jeu je vais
essayer de dire précisément ce que je
pense je pense que l'oeuvre que la tâche
qui est devant nous qui est devant les
français devant les gouvernants et les
citoyens français
cette tâche là elle est immense elle est
himalayenne on a devant nous des défis
des décisions à prendre qui sont qui
engagent notre avenir
je ne crois pas que cette politique
puisse être menée quand contretemps et
d'ailleurs si vous regardez avec
précision alors vous allez découvrir que
des partisans de cette politique comme
principe il y en a dans les deux camps
et que des ennemis de cette politique
il y en a aussi dans les deux camps ce
que je dis aux français depuis des
années c'est que les frontières des
camps ne passe plus au bon endroit il ya
des frontières il ya même des fractures
il ya des oppositions dans la vie
politique française mais elles ne sont
pas entre droite et gauche elles sont
entre les les plus radicaux de chaque
côté et ce que j'appelle la majorité
centrale et donc je vais jusqu'au bout
oui pour soutenir une telle politique et
relever de tels défis il faudra une
majorité d'unité nationale est ce que
les français sont prêts à vous écouter
je pense que il se passera peu de
semaine peu de mois avant que la réalité
ne fasse la pédagogie de tout ça il ya
des gens n'en très longtemps autour de
ces problèmes on avait du blabla on
avait du verre bu on avait des
discussions théoriques
on avait des affrontements partisans et
aujourd'hui c'est le réel qui est là la
france a rendez vous avec le réel
et elle ne peut pas éluder ce
rendez-vous même si la campagne
présidentielle n'a pas permis à ce
rendez-vous d'avoir lieu il ya déjà
quelque chose de très concret qui va
toucher français dans un premier temps
c'est le budget 2013 avec une réduction
de 30 millions d'impôts à l augmentation
une orientation une réduction des
dépenses publiques une réduction de 30
millions du déficit de oui enfin si on y
arrive c'est 30 milliards du déficit
nous sommes alors vous pensez que non
c'est difficile je veux c'est douter sur
un an dont le je me bats contre la dette
depuis 15 ans j'ai été je crois le
premier responsable politique français a
expliqué qu'elle était le mécanisme
implacable qui allait nous amener à de
très graves difficultés parce qu'on
laissait avec bêtise et laxisme ou
s'accumulent et la dette dans notre pays
aujourd'hui tout ça est devant nos yeux
donc c'est bien d'avoir choisi la kz2
réduire le déficit du pays simplement
françois hollande dit et la majorité
disent on va réduire le déficit
on va réduire les dépenses publiques de
10 milliards pour le budget est de 10
milliards pour la sécu c'est plus vite
dit que fait sa demande très gros effort
très assidus très soutenu et qu'ils
aillent jusqu'au bout mais c'est là
qu'on va voir s'appliquer la volonté
politique
j'avais pensé que c'est plus facile pour
un gouvernement de gauche qui arrivait
que d'un gouvernement de droite
oui oui c'est plus facile vous voyez
bien que réprimer les troubles quand
même un rêve agitation en mai et enfin
rien à voir même dans la rue mais vous
jouez
non j'ai pas dit dans la rue et les
années cas les mouvements sociaux je
pense qu'il y aura des conséquences
inéluctables
mais c'est évidemment le une des raisons
pour lesquelles il a été si difficiles
ces dernières années de faire la
politique de réformes que pourtant il
aurait fallu faire c'est s'est pas
seulement que les gouvernants ne
ne voyait pas les choses ou de nom c'est
que il y avait en france une opposition
de plus de 50% des français qui refusait
que ses décisions soient prises et qui
les combattent est aujourd'hui je citais
tout à l'heure la phrase que j'avais
utilisé au mois de mai aujourd'hui la
gauche découvre le réel et c'est
sûrement un choc pour un certain nombre
de ceux qui la forme mais c'est selon -
bien fait pour le pays
merci jean louis prévost alors vous
parlez vous misez sur une politique de
main d'unité nationale mais le principe
du relm oblige à rappeler que vos
troupes sont bien minces
françois bayrou de vote quoique ça n'a
aucune importance
d'accord la question de est-ce que vous
avez raison est ce que ce que vous dites
est vrai ne se mesure pas au nombre de
députés il peut y avoir des cas on l'a
vu dans l'histoire avant vous avez 90 %
des députés qui choisissent la mort et
la direction allait faire une arnaque je
joue et je préfère et de loin être en
phase en accord avec ce que je crois
juste pour mon pays d'être à la tête de
troupes nombreuses mais qu'ils se
trompent
terrain gras notre public sénat arrive
pour aborder d'autres aspects des
réformes qui mobilise également françois
bayrou notamment le fonctionnement de la
vie politique on se souvient du
référendum que vous aviez annoncé en cas
de victoire à la présidentielle françois
hollande on le sait il l'a rappelé
s'appuie sur les conclusions de la
commission jose pas alexandra colinot
moraliser la vie politique
c'était une promesse faite par françois
hollande à françois bayrou dans
l'entre-deux tours de la présidentielle
un gage pour obtenir son soutien au
second tour six mois plus tard les
propositions sont sur la table
parmi lesquelles l'élection de 10% des
députés à la proportionnelle
françois bayrou lui suggérait ce mode de
scrutin pour un quart des députés une
demi-mesure juge-t-on au sein même de la
commission
la crise politique la crise de confiance
entre les citoyens et ceux qui les
gouvernent et tél
qu'il faut des mesures fortes 10% 1 car
bon non c'est pas à la hauteur de la
crise il faut il faut on m'en parlait de
choc de compétitivité peut-être qu'il
faut un choc démocratique il faut un
choc institutionnels autre proposition
suggérée par le président du modem et
reprises dans le rapport de lionel
jospin
la limitation du cumul des mandats
député comme sénateur ne pourront plus
avoir de mandat exécutif local
mais à la haute assemblée ça ne passe
pas et c'est inciter au contraire a
montré du doigt les élus en des gens qui
ne sommes pas intègres qui ne sont pas
honnêtes alors que dans notre pays
beaucoup d'élus consacre beaucoup de
temps à la chose publique à l'intérêt
général
sans parler bien entendu et sans se
préoccuper des indemnités
nous sommes élus par des mères donc on
devrait pouvoir être sénateur et maire
ou alors ce soir lors de sa conférence
de presse françois hollande a néanmoins
confirmé que ces mesures seront soumises
au vote des parlementaires dès le début
de l'année prochaine un texte sera
préparé par le gouvernement et pour une
part se retrouvera dans une révision de
la constitution le cap donc effet que
c'est perrine tarneaud nous a rejoint un
grand soir non sans michel bonsoir
françois bayrou
quelle conclusion vous tirer du rapport
de lionel jospin est ce qu'on est loin
du choc institutionnels comme le disais
à l'instant dans le sujet dominique
rousseau le constitutionnaliste d'abord
il ya beaucoup de juste dans ce que
dominique rousseau dit en appelant à
aller plus loin
mais moi j'ai bon espoir que j'ai dans
l'espoir que dans les mois qui viennent
on va aller plus loin parce que une fois
que vous avez ouvert cette porte
alors vous vous apercevez des impasses
qui sont derrière la porte
alors je vous dire ce que je pense
d'abord je pense que sur le cumul des
mandats
enfin on va avoir des décisions et c'est
des décisions que tout le monde attend
et les
et la situation du parlement france
exige qu'on ait cette clarification qui
fasse que les parlementaires puissent
jouer tout leur rôle même s'il va y
avoir beaucoup de résistance y compris à
l'intérieur la majorité gouvernementale
et notamment ici au sénat écouter s'il
ya des résistances trop forte le
président de la république a des moyens
de les surmonter
mais quelle échelle le référendum auprès
des français pendant ce temps c'est pas
la voie qui a été choisie par françois
hollande là mais je comprends très bien
qu'ils ne la choisissent pas mais je dis
que si sur un point aussi important
aussi central dans l'engagement il y
avait des réticences et un refus absolu
de bouger alors que les sénateurs le
président ses responsabilités ce qui
pourrait y avoir un statut spécifique
pour les sénateurs c'est ce que réclame
françois rebsamen le patron du groupe ps
ici au sénat qui représente les
collectivités locales oui pourquoi pas
ah vous voyez bien que vous voyez bien
que tout ça fait six tomes vous voyez
bien que tout ce qu'il fait y avoir des
exceptions fait système non je je je ne
pense pas que ça tienne la route je vais
vous dire pourquoi parce que dès
l'instant que vous fait une exception
pour une assemblée vous déséquilibré le
rapport entre l'assemblée nationale et
le sénat
et vous avez soit une chambre de
deuxième rang soit au contraire une
chambre de privilèges et donc sur sin
passe
oui mais le bundesrat metal mind n'a pas
les prérogatives du sénat en france il
n'intervient que sur les textes qui
touchent que le nathalia de manière
décisive que sur les textes qui touchent
aux collectivités locales or les
sénateurs ils veulent intervenir de
manière décisive et à juste titre sur
tous les textes et donc à mon avis de ce
point de vue là il faut aller de l'avant
et être clair et net
évidemment le deuxième question c'est la
proportionnelle
alors on a alors il est évident que 10%
sans correctif ça quelque chose de
profondément déséquilibré
parce que vous avez une proportionnelle
qui va redonner
la portion la plus abondante aux partis
qui ont déjà tous les sièges donc il ya
quelque chose qui va pas mais nous avons
le temps de la discussion
président de la république a dit je vais
faire des consultations on aura
l'occasion de défendre auprès de lui un
autre point de vue et puis le temps des
dames à mort je veux simplement vous
rajoutez une phrase sibylline pour ceux
qui s'intéressent ou qu'ils considèrent
comme essentiels le fait qu'ils aient
une majorité à l'assemblée nationale
cette question peut être traité en même
temps que la représentativité des
courants minoritaires en france on peut
trouver un système en tout cas j'en
propose horaire on change de sujet
françois bayrou manuel valls elle qui
dérape et cet après midi à l'assemblée
nationale quand il a déclaré que la
droite avait favorisé le retour du
terrorisme en france
bon franchement c'est des mots qu'il
vaut mieux ne pas utiliser françois
hollande le lui a dit non non
infectueuses mans mais nettement oui
vous avez trouvé qu'il avait il a dit
c'est des cdc des mots et des arguments
qu'on n'utilise pas on ne met pas la
polémique dans le terrorisme on est
obligé de rassembler oui je pense que
c'est vraiment pas des arguments à
utiliser je crois que son expression a
dépassé sa pensée
vous ne demandez pas sa démission comme
françois fillon ce soir je ne suis pas
en campagne pour la présidence
on va en parler oui on va en parler dans
quelques minutes une interview inédite
ce matin dans le figaro de patrick
buisson
l'ancien conseiller de nicolas sarkozy
qui observe une radicalisation des
esprits à chaque fois que la gauche est
au pouvoir
est ce que vous observez la même chose
que lui c'est une radicalisation des
esprits qu'il souhaite
il dit que c'est une loi d'airain c'est
la radicalisation des esprits qui l'a
choisie comme ligne politique
peut-être parce que c'est sa nature
vassieux sans aucun doute parce que
c'est sa nature profonde
mais c'est une radicalisation à laquelle
tout le monde travail y compris et
surtout un certain nombre de
tendu tout le monde les parties de
leader de la droite donc évidemment
c'est pas une conséquence c'est c'est le
sait ou plutôt c'est la conséquence des
choix qui ont été faits par par patrick
buisson et et ceux qui l'écoutent
mais quand vous dites tout le monde il
travaille a droit tous les leaders de la
droite actuelle à l'elysée
hier soir le droit de les citer françois
leur nom françois fillon a fait hier
soir un discours qui est au contraire un
discours de rassemblement et que j'ai
trouvé responsable
d'ailleurs il a appelé à la droite à la
gauche au centre mais c est à noter
n'est ce pas
si vous regardez je vous supplie de ne
pas tout considérée sous l'angle
politique ou politiciens si vous
regardez la situation de notre pays
alors vous ne pouvez conclure qu'une
chose on ne s'en sortira que tous
ensemble
en tout cas tous ceux qui partagent les
objectifs principaux de notre avenir
national c'est-à-dire l'avenir de la
france se fait avec l'europe et pas
contre l'europe
l'avenir de la france fait avec les
entreprises et pas contre les
entreprises
l'avenir de la france se fait avec
l'éducation et la recherche est pas
contre l'éducation et la recherche
tous ceux qui partagent ces objectifs là
quelque chose à faire ensemble
l'unité nationale que vous appelez de
vos voeux petite question sur le centre
quand même pour finir cette émission est
ce que vous en est réduit pour reprendre
la main au centre à attendre une
éventuelle dérobade de jean louis borloo
qui pourra exemple pourraient se lasser
de lui d ici un an mais me jean louis
borloo a fait ses choix
j'ai fait les tenir la ligne politique
n'est pas là il vous avez dit que vous
étiez prêts à travailler jean louis
borloo et ses amis pensent qu'il faut
que le centre soit à droite soit dans un
temps et même ils le disent
explicitement et moi je pense qu'il faut
que le centre soit au centre et
indépendants
ça n'empêche pas de travailler ensemble
et jean louis borloo espère une
radicalisation aussi l'ump
ben oui bien sûr mais justement - pas
vous comprenez la différence entre ce
qui est jeu les jeux qu'on joue et ce
qui est fond
moi j'espère qu'il y aura en france la
constitution de d'un rassemblement
capable de sortir le pays de la
situation désespérante dans laquelle il
se trouve
mais je peux pas appeler al
intenrationales et rejeté ou dire que je
travaillerai jamais avec des gens qui
ont été les uns et les autres à d'autres
époques
avant de partir dans d'autres aventures
à l'ump en particulier de mes proches ou
de mes amis je dis que la france a
besoin d'un centre qui soit un centre de
rassemblement et je le pratique alors
car il ya eu beaucoup avec orange et
leur application
c'est une des réflexions acerbes souvent
sur vos françois bayrou il faut le dire
oui alors il ya des questions comme
celle de xavier comment pensez-vous
pouvoir servir la france
concrètement dans votre position
actuelle il yad'autres effectivement
remarque un peu plus acerbes qui
représentez vous aujourd'hui dit liliane
et bien h1n1 présente je représente des
millions de français qui attendent que
la vie politique change et deviennent en
fait responsable qui en ont marre qu'ils
sont désespérés de ces jeux dans
lesquels vous voyez bien chacun fait de
la surenchère sur l'autre regardez
l'assemblée nationale c'est votre métier
franchement on peut pas considérer que
la manière dont le débat s'organise à
l'assemblée nationale soit une manière
qui puisse faire avancer un pays on a
besoin d'avoir des gens qui soient pas
uniquement dans le jeu de rôle les uns
toujours pour et l'autre toujours contre
ça ne manquent pas quand même un peu ces
débats l'assemblée nationale pas du tout
que répondez vous à ceux et ils sont
nombreux à la fois sur twitter et puis
sorti vite fait qu'elle dira il a trahi
bayrou et pourquoi est-ce que vous
l'invitez encore et bien précisément
parce que je n'ai pas trahi et de ma vie
je n'ai jamais envisagé la moins de
trahison à l'égard de ce que je croyais
simplement il ya des gens qui auraient
voulu que nous soyons constamment
prisonniers de la logique des camps il
se trouve
que de cette logique dé quand j'ai voulu
que nous nous aimons six pions j'ai
voulu que nous libérions parce que c'est
les camps qui nous ont menés où nous
sommes
vous croyez qu'on en serait dans un pays
dans lequel il ya des dizaines de
milliers de chômeurs de plus par an
depuis 12 ans si les responsables
politiques avaient été sérieux croyez ça
d'autre part l'intérieur d'un camp mais
peut-être à une fonction à un poste qui
vous intéresseraient en particulier vous
allez me dire que vous n'êtes candidat à
rien je l'aimais quoi l'avoir concret si
vous voulez me faire ce crédit si vous
voulez avoir l'objectivité de dieu gg
souvent refusé d'entrer dans des
gouvernements que je que je que je
n'approuvais pas dans leur orientation
alors là si les conditions sont réunies
on a compris depuis le début de cette
émission mais vous vous trompez pas bon
est ce que vous êtes quand même candidat
un rendez vous avec le chef de l'état je
sais pas dans les semaines qui viennent
on mais quand j'ai des rendez vous avec
que françois hollande ne les rend pas
public et c'est beaucoup mieux comme ça
mais dont vous nous confirmez vous le
voyez temps à autre je n'ai jamais de ma
vie
rencontrer un président de la république
pour faire la publicité de cette
rencontre ni quand c'était françois
mitterrand j'ai été son ministre
et puis après j'ai été au gouvernement
alors qu'il n'était plus président ni
quand c'était jacques chirac ni quand
c'était nicolas sarkozy ni quand le
président de la république s'appelle
françois hollande sait comment vous dire
ça c'est une élégance minimal de
considérer que quand on a des rapports
de confiance avec quelqu'un on va pas
l'étaler sur la place publique parce que
ça c'est franchement pas à la hauteur
des responsabilités qui sont les nôtres
merci françois bayrou après vous avoir
écouté peut-être françois hollande lui
sera peut-être b0 de vous rencontrer
prochainement pour que vous me suis dit
tiens lui regard de ces propos que vous
avez tenus ce soir merci merci monsieur
le président du modem le mouvement
démocrate alvaro
bonsoir